[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbwegs guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den spanierinnen tor von mir wir
haben unter anderem diese themen für sie
die grünen stellen sich neu auf ricarda
lang und omid nouripour werden zum neuen
spitzenduo gewählt
italien sucht einen präsidenten 7
wahlgänge waren erfolglos jetzt soll der
80 jährige amtsinhaber materieller noch
mal ran
und gelungene generalprobe vor olympia
kombinierer vinzenz geiger holt sich im
seefeld seinen zweiten saisonsieg
16 jahre lang waren die grünen in der
opposition unter dem führungsduo habeck
und baerbock haben sie ihre
mitgliederzahl fast verdoppelt und den
sprung in die regierung geschafft jetzt
übernehmen zwei mal die führung
weil annalena baerbock und robert habeck
jetzt minister ämter haben geben sie
nach vier jahren den parteivorsitz ab
und zwar an diese beiden
bundestagsabgeordneten die junge partei
linke ricarda lang und den außenpolitik
experte omid nouripour vom grünen
parteitag berichtet dangel putzen ja ich
nehme die wahl an vielen vielen dank ich
kann ziemlich geraten die freude der
gerade gewählten kandidaten gegen ein
bisschen und wegen einer corona
infektion barrikade lang nur
zugeschaltet ihre freude über 75,9
prozent zustimmung schmälerte dies
offenkundig nicht ebenso dankbar und
zufrieden wenig später mit nouripour der
82,6 prozent erhielt in ihren reden
hatten beide zuvor betont die grünen
regierungsmitglieder zu unterstützen
gleichzeitig aber das profil der partei
zu wahren und weiterzuentwickeln wir
machen politik und das leben von
menschen komplett zu verbessern um
unsere lebensgrundlage zu erhalten und
dafür trete ich an einem
spannungsverhältnis zwischen eine partei
nicht viel verändern will und der
realität eine regierung was zu erreichen
für diese menschen und für diesen
planeten und dafür bin ich gerne bereit
auch meine schwierige situation
auszuhalten lang 28 aus baden
württemberg zuvor parteivize und seit
kurzem bundestagsabgeordnete gehört dem
linken parteilager an außenpolitiker
nouripour 46 gebürtiger iraner und seit
18 jahren im bundestag zuletzt mit
überzeugendem wahlkreis in frankfurt ist
real beide betonten das ziel der
geschlossenheit was wie bei nouripour
entlang eine kritische selbstbetrachtung
jedoch nicht verhindern solle wir werden
den wahlkampf zusammen nach arbeiten um
das nächste mal noch erfolgreicher zu
sein und auch strukturen zu schaffen die
uns ermöglichen mit geschlossenheit und
mit den erfolgen die wir erzielen werden
wieder in der k-frage mitspielen zu
können zuvor war es vor allem ein tag
des abschieds neben der bisherigen
doppelspitze gilt das auch für
bundesgeschäftsführer kellner sie alle
sind nun regierungsmitglieder dass es
damit der partei gelegentlich zu
reibungen kommen werde so berger
kontrabass sei programmiert und durchaus
auch bekommen
[Musik]
fragen wir patricia wiedemeier in berlin
was sind die unterschiede zwischen den
neuen und ihren vorgängern
na ja da gibt es schon große
unterschiede muss ich sagen also zum
einen ist ricarda lang gerade mal 28
jahre alt damit die jüngste aller grünen
vorsitzenden und sie gehört dem linken
flügel an und mit nouripour ist real und
gebürtiger iraner für die grünen ein
ganz wichtiges zeichen dass sie nicht
nur einen minister mit
migrationshintergrund haben sondern
jetzt auch einen parteivorsitzende die
bisherige ungewohnte einigkeit an der
spitze von habig und baerbock wird es in
der form vielleicht auch nicht mehr
geben ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
deutlich mehr und kontroverser künftig
diskutiert wird über den kurs der partei
und auch dieser neue politikstil den
robert habeck ja geprägt hat mit seiner
art zu reden mit seiner art zu
philosophieren den wird es in dieser
form auch nicht mehr geben zumindest
nicht an der spitze der partei noch ganz
kurz was ist die größte herausforderung
für die beiden neuen jetzt
ich zitiere da mal omid nouripour er hat
gesagt die schwierigste aufgabe der
partei wird es künftig sein der
regierung zu sagen was die basis so will
und der basis dann zu erklären warum die
regierung das nicht macht genau um
diesen spagat geht es also die partei
darf der regierung keine knüppel
zwischen die beine werfen wie das damals
unter rot grün war andererseits muss sie
an ihrem eigenen profil arbeiten sie
muss für neue programme sorgen sie muss
für neue ideen sorgen dass alles dann in
die regierung einzubringen und weiter
das gesicht zu wahren und präsent zu
bleiben neben starken ministern und
einer starken fraktion das wird keine
leichte aufgabe
dankeschön nach berlin patrick
wiedemeyer
wir sind ricarda lang und omid nouripour
wofür stehen sie mehr zu ihrem
politischen werdegang haben wir online
zusammengefasst unter zdf heute oder in
unserer zdf heute
am ersten oktober soll nicht nur der
mindestlohn auf 12 euro steigen sondern
auch die obergrenze für minijobs von
450 auf 520 euro das kündigte
arbeitsminister
kritik kommt von den gewerkschaften sie
befürchten dass mini jobs immer mehr
reguläre arbeitsplätze verdrängen zudem
seien sie eine teilzeit falle gerade für
frauen zur krone situation in
deutschland da steigen die zahlen weiter
laut robert koch institut gab es binnen
eines tages mehr als
189.000 neuinfektionen das sind rund
53.000 700 mehr als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 182 todesfälle dazu die
sieben tage incidents steigt mit 1100
27,7 auf einen neuen höchstwert
auch heute sind in mehreren städten
wieder gegner der korona maßnahmen auf
die straße gegangen in freiburg waren
nach schätzungen der polizei
4500 demonstranten unterwegs sie
protestierten unter anderem gegen eine
mögliche impfpflicht nennenswerte
zwischenfälle gab es nicht auch in
bochum hamburg und neumarkt zogen
menschen durch die innenstädte in bochum
versammelten sich auch gegen
demonstranten
nichts mit ruhestand italiens präsident
matt arena ist nun doch bereit für eine
zweite amtszeit eigentlich wollte sich
der 80-jährige das nicht antun doch auch
im siebten wahlgang heute konnten sich
die zerstrittenen parteien in rom nicht
auf einen nachfolger oder eine
nachfolgerin einigen dem anschließenden
werben aus den verschiedenen politischen
lagern gab materieller dann
andreas postel in rom anfangs schien der
populäre ministerpräsident draghi ganz
gute karten zu haben jetzt läuft es doch
wieder auf einen mann raus der dieses
amt eigentlich gar nicht mehr haben will
was ist da los in italien
sieht so aus der alte wird der neue
seien zwar läuft hier hinter mir im
parlamentsgebäude in rom die abstimmung
noch und das ergebnis ist natürlich
abzuwarten aber im laufe des tages
mehrten sich die stimmen die bereit sind
zetsche materielle erneut zu wählen und
das gezerre um seine nachfolge zu
beenden dass die 1009 grandi tory die
wahlfrauen und wahlmänner hier aus ganz
italien eine woche lang nicht in der
lage waren sich auf eine respektable
persönlichkeit für höchste staatsamt zu
entscheiden weil wir einen rückfall in
alte zeiten und der heimliche favorit
mario draghi dem erkennen dass der
wechsel vom regierungsamt in den kirchen
als palast wohl viel schwieriger gewesen
wäre und viel zu riskant für die
regierung gewesen wäre die italiener
wollen ihn wohl eher als regierungschef
behalten eine zweite amtszeit jetzt von
sergio materieller scheint zu
garantieren dass italien auf seinem
konsolidierungskurs weiter machen kann
andreas postel live aus rom dankeschön
zum ukraine konflikt die usa wollen
weitere soldaten in die osteuropäischen
nato staaten verlegen das kündigte us
präsident biden an ohne weitere details
zu nennen russland verstärkt derweil
seine militärpräsenz in belarus und
schickt weitere rüstungsgüter an die
grenze zur ukraine
darunter kurzstrecken abwehrraketen zu
übungszwecken wie es heißt bereits zuvor
hatte moskau um mehrere kampfflieger in
das gebiet verlegt
in der ukraine schürt das die angst vor
einem krieg gerade auch im osten des
landes etwa in der großstadt mariupol
ganz in der nähe die vom prorussischen
kräfte selbst ernannte volksrepublik
denn jetzt außerdem die russische grenze
und die von russland annektierte grimm
aus der hafenmetropole mario pohl
berichtet anna
verlassen wirkt die kriegsmarine der
hafenstadt mariupol sollte russland vom
meer aus angreifen dann würden sie die
achillesferse der ukrainischen
streitkräfte treffen mit mehr als der
doppelten truppenstärke sollen russische
kriegsschiffe irgendwo da draußen im
asowschen meer warten die eroberung der
hafenstadt könnte dann für sie ein
leichtes werden
wir beobachten hier täglich
grenzverletzungen unseres hoheitsgebiets
wir sichten täglich die kriegsflotte der
russischen streitkräfte
des russischen geheimdienstes und der
schwarzmeerflotte immer wieder kommt es
zu systematischen überschreitungen der
drei meilen zone sie kommen ist ein
special das sei eine offene provokation
sagt uns der offizier aber mehr kann er
auch nicht sagen jedes falsche wort
können für bedrohlich schärfen und nur
16 kilometer liegt mario pohl von der
frontlinie entfernt die narben der
kämpfe von 2014 im stadtbild
allgegenwärtig
an der östlichen ausläufern eine fischer
siedlung die männer hier bewachen für
den grenzen des den strandabschnitt
dieser krieg sei ein künstlicher findet
andrea schuld sei der westen es ist eine
fehde zwischen amerika und russland und
die ukraine ist ein opfer wir wurden
gewaltsam in einen von uns ungewollten
konflikt gezwungen und jetzt der
russischstämmige ukraine sagt er werde
im falle eines angriffs nicht kämpfen
sollte deutschland seiner meinung nach
waffen an die ukraine liefern
wenn es keine waffen gibt kann man auch
nicht schießen wenn man dagegen waffen
hat dann benutzt man sie auch deshalb
meine ich ohne waffen kein krieg
sein wunsch sein friedensverhandlungen
zwischen der ukraine und russland
denn er findet lieber ein fragiler
frieden als ein großer krieg
wie gestaltet ein land die wahl einer
neuen regierung wenn viele der
wählerinnen und wähler mit corona
infiziert oder in quarantäne sind
portugal hat sich da einiges einfallen
lassen seit einer woche darf gewählt
werden erwartet wird ein kopf an kopf
rennen zwischen den beiden grössten
parteien den regierenden sozialisten und
den liberalkonservativen aus lissabon
thomas walter wenn er wähler nicht so
ohne können kommt die urne zu den
wählern beamte besuchen den zentral ein
altersheim ein zehntel der portugiesen
hat kuh wird oder ist kontakt soll und
darf nicht raus andere haben angst sich
im wahllokal zu infizieren und briefwahl
gibt es nicht
wir wollen garantieren dass die leute
bequem wählen können und zwar ohne in
die öffentlichkeit gehen zu müssen und
gefahr zu laufen sich mit 19 anzustecken
auch inhaltlich bestimmt kurve die wahl
die sozialisten von premierminister
antonio costa hier beim
wahlkampfabschluss in lissabon wollen
die sozialen folgen der pandemie mildern
und den wohlfahrtsstaat ausbauen
wir haben jetzt schon eine
arbeitslosigkeit die niedriger ist als
vor der pandemie das heißt wir sind
bereit für die vollständige erholung der
wirtschaft die liberal- konservativen
dagegen wollen steuern senken um die
wirtschaft nach der pandemie anzukurbeln
war es kein auf diese wahlentscheidung
ist extrem wichtig für unser land trotz
der pandemie sie ist ein wendepunkt denn
portugal bekommt milliarden aus
europäischen fonds und muss damit die
weichen für die zukunft stellen
so führt kurve zu einer richtungswahl
wer am ende im parlament die mehrheit
bekommt um die beteiligung zu erhöhen
erlaubt die regierung infizierten am
wahltag ihre quarantäne zu brechen sie
sollen zwischen 18 und 19 uhr in die
wahllokale gehen bei völlig unklar ist
wie viele portugiesen mitten in der
pandemie wählen gehen werden gilt auch
der ausgang dieser wahl als völlig offen
über die us amerikanische ostküste fegt
ein mächtiger schneesturm die behörden
in den bundesstaaten new york und new
jersey haben den ausnahmezustand
ausgerufen
tausende flüge wurden gestrichen für 70
millionen menschen gelten
unwetterwarnungen nina niebergall hat
der kreis
der bomben schneesturm wie die
meteorologen nennen hat die straßen von
boston so gut wie leer gefegt nicht
rausgehen warnen die behörden die
mischung aus schnee und wind in
hurrikanstärke sei gefährlich man könne
leicht die orientierung verlieren an der
küste von neuengland bringt der wind
sturmfluten die menschen sollten ihre
häuser verlassen sich in sicherheit
bringen
wir haben sandsäcke sorgt und im keller
alles hoch gestellt das ist einer der
schlimmsten stürme die ich gesehen habe
zehntausende sind an der ostküste ohne
strom in roth island ist das autofahren
nur noch im notfall erlaubt
new york hat es nicht so schlimm
erwischt zwar sollen die menschen auch
hier am besten zu hause bleiben aber
fast ein halber meter schnee mitten in
manhattan das sieht man schließlich
nicht jeden tag
das ist einfach ein schöner schnee tag
im winter
ich bin so glücklich darüber ich liebe
schnee was gefällt dir am schnee alex
dass sich schneeballschlachten machen
darf
weiter nördlich soll der sturm noch bis
sonntagmorgen bieten bis dahin heißt es
zu hause bleiben oder so schnell wie
möglich nach hause kommen
ungemütlich bis gefährlich kann es auch
in norddeutschland werden dort zieht
gerade ein sturm auf der in der nacht
orkan böen bringen soll an der nordsee
gab es schon am nachmittag die ersten
vorboten für die küste wird mit einer
sturmflut gerechnet in hamburg und bei
wilhelmshaven sind bereits erste bäume
umgestürzt und extremer wind ist auch
für den brocken im harz angekündigt erst
mal wo früher soll sich das wetter dann
beruhigen
heftigen wind gab es auch in hessen beim
skispringen in willingen
der hatte auch folgen sehen wir gleich
die deutschen männer die haben heute
nicht so gut abgeschnitten dafür lief es
bei den frauen besser dank katharina
althaus die rang zwei belegte übrigens
das erste mal dass die frauen im weltcup
von einer großschanzen springen
ein küsschen von katharina althaus platz
zwei für die deutsche bei der premiere
der skispringerinnen in villingen der
sieg bei windigen bedingungen in nur
einem durchgang geht an die
österreicherinnen sara maria kramer mit
einer weite von 123 einhalb metern vor
althaus und der slowenin immer kleenex
selina freitag übersteht einen heftigen
sturz von der mühlenkopfschanze mit
schürfwunden aber offenbar ohne
gravierende verletzungen
beim skispringen der männer in villingen
triumphierte japaner review kobayashi
ebenfalls in nur einem durchgang vor den
norwegern hall wagner geriet und marius
lind weg severin freund landete als
bester von vier deutschen in den top 15
auf platz vier karl geiger aber wird
unter schwierigen bedingungen nur
zwanzigster
und vinzenz geiger der feiert beim
nordic triple in seefeld seinen zweiten
saisonsieg nach einer taktisch
überragenden laufleistung zweiter der
österreicher johannes lampater dritter
der norweger jürgen groh back
vinzenz geiger der strahlende sieger
beim weltcup saison höhepunkt in tirol
übernimmt damit die führung und hat die
beste ausgangsposition für den morgigen
schlusstag mit einem starken sprung auf
100,5 meter legt der oberstdorfer eine
gute grundlage für das 10 kilometer
langlauf rennen von rang sechs kämpft er
sich nach vorne und dringend auf den
letzten metern den im weltcup führenden
johannes lamparter aus österreich nieder
elf tage vor dem ersten wettkampf der
kombinierer bei den spielen in peking
zeigen sich geiger und die gesamte
deutsche mannschaft in topform
eric frenzel auf platz vier terence
weber und julian schmid auf den rängen
fünf und sechs
ski rennläuferin kira weidler hat bei
der letzten weltcup abfahrt vor den
olympischen spielen in peking das podest
haarscharf verpasst
beim wettbewerb auf der kandahar in
garmisch-partenkirchen fehlten ihr nur
vier hundertstel sekunden zur
drittplatzierten cornelia hütter aus
österreich siegerin die schweizerin
corinne suter
wintersport und die olympischen spiele
in peking das sind die top themen heute
abend bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio
um 23 uhr zu gast die osb präsident
thomas weikert
lokalmatadorin ashley partie hat es
geschafft nach 44 jahren wieder ein
heimsieg bei den australian open
die nummer eins der tennis-weltrangliste
unten im bild bezwang in melbourne die
überraschungs finalistin daniel collins
aus den usa mit 6 3 7 6 im zweiten satz
holte partie einen 1 5 rückstand auf und
gewann schließlich im tie break der
dritte grand slam titel für die
australien und sein 21 grand slam titel
könnte morgen im finale rafael nadal
gegen madoffs gewinnen sind wir gespannt
vielen dank an nord und ostseeküste
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst bis
morgen früh vor orkanartigen böen mehr
zum orkantief hat auch gleich ist intern
das heute journal um viertel vor elf mit
christian sievers danke für ihr
interesse wir wünschen ihnen noch ein
schönes wochenende uns in morgen wieder
da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter orkantief nadya hatte uns
erreicht und die windrichtung würde auf
nord bis nordwest drehen und so gibt es
eine sturmflutwarnung für allem für die
nordseeküste und für die ostsee ja und
die windgeschwindigkeiten die schauen
wir uns hier an 120 bis 130 kilometer
pro stunde an den küsten auch hohe
windgeschwindigkeiten in
mecklenburg-vorpommern und in berlin
orkanartige böen um 105 kilometer pro
stunde und das legte im laufe der nacht
zu dieser winzer aus nordwestlichen
richtungen dazu gibt es regen graupel
und schneeschauer die sich allmählich
nach südosten verlagern bei tiefsten
temperaturen von null bis fünf grad und
morgen am vormittag gibt es noch diese
hohen windgeschwindigkeiten im nordosten
deutschlands lässt erst im tagesverlauf
allmählich nach regen und schnee
verabschieden sich nach südosten viel
sonne im westen bei temperaturen von
drei bis neun grad und die nächsten tage
sind sehr wechselhaft mit regen und
schnee vor allem an den alpen auch
ergiebig dazu gibt es sturmböen montag
ein bis sieben grad und der dienstag ist
so ähnlich damit ein schöner abend